the great resignation has millions of
workers turning their hobbies and side
hustles into businesses and now a
trending app is helping entrepreneurs go
to market in seconds
it's always hard to showcase what you're
doing twenty-year-old annie elise is
finishing up her studies at berkeley
college of music in boston originally a
classically trained violinist annie
developed an interest in electronic
music she's been an active songwriter
and producer and now showcasing her own
talents as an artist of commercial pop
with electronic influences
[Music]
working freelance to pay the bills i
feel like one of the biggest things that
came out of the pandemic for people that
are kind of freelance workers is that
we're really in charge of
you know the the content that we make
and the things that we put out and and
we're not really working we're just
working for ourselves it can be really
hard to push that without the help of
anyone she started using the universe
app to build a creative website and
brand and ultimately connect with
customers she just released her song
again and again and saw a 270 percent
increase in pre-saves of her music
thanks to the app i think it is
definitely the future of links and bios
for
social media influencers users
freelancers before she says people would
only be able to find her artist project
or producer project but now she says the
app allows her to showcase both equally
[Music]
annie's interest in electronic music
stems from a neurological condition she
refers to herself as a conductor for
color as she creates music that produces
colors she likes to see